ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show
real fun episode jeff garland
star of curb your enthusiasm will be
joining us later on in the broadcast
great to talk to jeff big fan of curb
which you
uh you hate that show no no no i like
that show a lot i hate it
you hate it and you hate larry david and
you hate jerry seinfeld and you hate
everything you're the one who hates
no i'm kidding ben loves the show
nothing not to love
we just thought we saw a brown recluse
spider
uh outside of my home get the photo up
that i posted and it's not a brown
recluse it is a southern
house spider but we didn't know
we didn't know common mistake common
mistake and of course you put something
like that up on twitter and uh
you know i don't know why when i do
something like that i think i'm gonna
get like an entomologist
who's like actually it's just people
responding you're a fat recluse
and i'm like that's not particularly
helpful in this situation
but it is a male ku
ku kuku kanya
it is a southern house spider
thank you someone in a facebook spider
group with emotional problems
just just classifying spiders anytime
day or night
just a happy person
a lot of people you know they're all
these brown recluse spiders are all over
austin texas
and it is a big you know thing there was
actually a big
lawsuit because a guy a caretaker at an
airbnb
was bit by a brown recluse spent 75 days
in a hospital
uh spent 600 000 on medical expenses
it wound all the way up the case went to
the texas
supreme court and then eventually they
sided with the
homeowner let's take a listen this is
the news okay
let's take a listen it's the spider bite
lawsuit
why am i leaving here i don't know it's
the lawsuit about the spider bite
that went to the supreme court
i think the legal spider bite in the
hill country has turned into a
lengthy legal battle between two men
look at this guy
can we get out of here please keep look
at this
i mean this guy
he likes spiders to bite him he can only
come if spiders are biting him
he has a hooker take a brown recluse and
and it
bites him and that's how he can come all
right anyway continue this i'm sure he's
a lovely man
the supreme court kxan's alex capriello
shows us why this case has been so hard
for the courts to resolve
and we want to warn you some of the
images you are about to see
may be considered graphic
it was a cold day in december 65 year
old henry mccall a caretaker at an
airbnb
property reached under the single please
start
this is like they're shooting it to be
like like very dramatic
he's like some of the images are
disturbing
because they're of poor people now some
i want to
give you fair warning some of the images
are disturbing because they are of
people who clean houses
for a living be considered graphic
it was a cold day in december 65 year
old henry mccall a caretaker at an
airbnb
property in fredericksburg reached out
to the sink to fix it
it was a cold day in december uh a 97
year old caretaker like the guy's 65
he's a caretaker i feel horrible what
does that even mean
caretaker of an airbnb by the way that's
like a term that's used
that was like jack torrance in the
shining
he's a caretaker of an airbnb
the guy's 65 years old and he's just i
think attacked by brown reclasses but
the prick on his arm
the highly poisonous spider caused
mccall's arm to bruise and swell
he spent 75 days in the hospital
underwent six surgeries and spent nearly
six hundred thousand dollars on hospital
bills
but for the grace of god you know
i'm still here and i'm great and he goes
and i'm
for his suffering saying he should be
liable since he didn't warn him of the
possible danger in his bnb
attorneys tell us he normally wouldn't
be since those animals are native to the
land
similar legal cases regarding indigenous
animal biting and attacking people have
all taken place
outdoors so now the texas supreme court
judges will hear both sides
on whether or not a landowner has a duty
to protect the people on their property
if that fight happens indoors mccall
claims hillis knew about the infestation
mccall says he saw a full-size mattress
and frame at the home crawling with
spiders
but hillary's claims he had an
exterminator come and take care of the
property several times
he also mentions his stellar online
reviews which never mention an insect
problem
hilus also points out any judgment that
makes him laugh
by the way for anyone who operates that
looks like a prison that's true it's the
property in the hill take a look at that
that's an airbnb that looks like a like
a youth detention facility
that's an airbnb that can't be it who in
god's that's
it who in god's name is
paying money to stay in that airbnb
by the side of the highway with this
poor elderly caretaker
i mean and the texas supreme court tells
the guy to go [ __ ] himself
yeah they go hey the spiders were here
before you
sir
should we finish this yeah of course
hilus also points out
any judgment that makes him liable will
be detrimental for
anyone who operates a property in the
hill country hopefully
they will bring about some regulations
to exterminate
for bed bugs for scorpions
for brown recluse spiders and black
wiggle spiders alex capriello kxan news
we reached out to the airbnb owner homer
hillis as well as his lawyer
they chose not to comment until the
texas supreme court makes their decision
homer
judges will hear both arguments the
airbnb owner
homer hillis my name is homer hilus
i run an airbnb and there are some
spiders in there but they're native to
the land
and my caretaker who's 115 years old
ended up getting bit he had to spend 75
days
and by the way can you like look at that
that is not what should be done at like
a hospital that
that stitching looks like it was done by
a child
what thank i pray i don't need any
medical attention in this state ever i
pray to god
i don't need to go to a hospital here
look at that looks like a witch did it
my name is homer hilas i run a youth
detention center
that i also use as an airbnb and there's
there's black widows and brown recluses
in every room
and my caretaker was near keeled and he
sued
me homer helus god
but we thought look at this new teenage
suspect identified in austin
6th street mass shooting charges dropped
against two teens
tonight austin police are searching for
close call for those two
a new suspect has been identified in the
june 12 mass shooting on sixth street
in austin that killed one man and
injured 14 others charges have been
dropped against two teenagers who were
previously arrested
in connection with the shooting
authorities said at a press conference
tuesday
austin police department reports
19-year-old deandre
jamiris white will have been charged
with murder his bond is set at a million
dollars
white is responsible for the murder of
the victim 25 year old douglas cantor
who's visiting austin [ __ ]
interim apd chief joseph
chacon said new witnesses statements and
evidence that led to charges in the case
according to chacon
investigators believe white fired the
shots after analyzing
ballistic missile evidence and
surveillance uh camera footage
yeah it's policing yeah
based on now multiple witnesses
ballistic evidence
video evidence we know white was the
person who fired
the handgun striking mr cantor and
multiple other victims police say they
interviewed white
following the shooting but he was
released and returned to colleen
that's good according to the apd he
changed his hair in appearance before
going into hiding
i mean who is
in charge here this is the new city
this is uh jesus
white is still at large and should be
considered armed and dangerous but then
did they get him is he got now
yeah cause they they got him right they
finally got him yeah
they need to change the tents of this
yeah
jeez i mean that's [ __ ] up somebody
goes and visits austin
and there's a mass shooting not good
very sad dude this is [ __ ] up somebody
was paralyzed i mean this is
absolutely insane
so they one 17-year-old was spent a week
in jail and he didn't even do it
that's crazy austin mayor shootings
victims family speaks out after suspect
identified yeah i mean this stuff is
very sad
and uh you know hopefully this guy is
convicted and spends the rest of his
life
in jail because that
is um what needs to happen to somebody
who is um trying to murder everyone
i know that people like abolish prisons
well i know
but i think perhaps we do need some of
them
yes it would be a bad idea to
where would he go if not a prison this
guy we'd put him in a mental hospital
he could room with my mother
you know they could watch tucker carlson
together
they could watch tucker carlson tonight
because that's the solution right
if we abolish prisons he goes into some
type of
facility i mean that's i'm giving the
people
the benefit of the doubt he goes into a
facility with my mother and they watch
taco calls in the night
or he we just let him out
i don't understand does he go to the
vulcan gas company and and perform
help me out does he do kill tony what
happens to him
get rid of this this is very sad uh
mental health
and and mental health awareness is such
a theme of the show
because of my mother is a schizophrenic
and i always want to make
sure that people are that are having
mental problems
reach out before something horrible
happens
before they do something to themselves
or others we do not have
a lot of adequate mental health care in
this country now that being said
it's sad when people who are
they feel that they're at the end of
their rope and they don't have anyone to
reach out to they feel like that
do something drastic like commit suicide
this is very sad
and this happens far too often um
it's horribly tragic always but it's
especially tragic when there's someone
like accomplished when they're let's say
a writer and they've written a book
that's sad because they've they wrote a
book
and then and had a family and and had
no uh a prior
um uh mental health concerns at all
they'd never
voiced at all that they were suicidal
and they were on tv
several weeks before they kill
themselves that's how insidious mental
health is
that's how insidious mental health is
that it can just out of nowhere
with no warning or no indication when
you seem absolutely fine
to everyone around you you can just kill
yourself
out of the blue and the this man
wrote a book about bill and hillary
clinton and this is sad
because many of the people that these
two are connected to have mental
problems
and end up uh taking their own lives
um this is very very sad
and uh get this up because this guy
uh he wrote a book about when bill
clinton
confronted loretta lynch on the tarmac
about the investigation
into hillary's uh emails and lynch was
the attorney general
and uh uh there was a
tv anchor i believe
um and this person
police in alabama said this week and
they are investigating the death of the
television news reporter who broke a
story in 2016 about a secret
tarmac meeting between former president
clinton and former attorney general
loretta lynch as a suicide
lieutenant keith whatever i don't know
how to pronounce that with the hoover
police department
uh they love investigating this by the
way they're they're in hog heaven down
there um
they're saying signs death is being
investigated as a suicide
our deepest empathy is shared with
chris's loving family and close
friends said sinclair broadcast
group um while in phoenix
sign broke the story about a tarmac
meeting between lynch and clinton
which came as former president obama's
justice department was investigating
the former secretary of state hillary
clinton then running for president over
the use of her private email server
for official government uh business when
i broke the story we knew that something
had occurred here that was a bit unusual
sign said of the meeting during an
appearance on fox news that year
it was a planned meeting it was not a
coincidence this details everything they
don't want you to know and everything
they think you forgot
now i thought he wrote a book about that
did he not write a book
i believe he did let me see this will be
another example by the way
of tim dylan being right-wing he's a
right-wing
psychopath he's pointing out
something that's weird you know the
heroes of the progressive movement
bill and hillary clinton
christopher signed birmingham tv anchor
and former alabama football
star player died in apparent suicide
i believe he did right maybe it wasn't
didn't he write a book
isn't there something on didn't he say
he was got a lot of threats when that
happened
let's see here yeah secret on the tarmac
here we go on amazon right
yeah he wrote this book secret on the
tarmac
it's amazing that he was able to get a
book done while
suffering from a debilitating mental
illness some serious depression
inside the clandestine tarmac meeting of
bill clinton and the red lynch the story
of her journalism
a secret informant and alabama football
impacted a presidential election
yeah well
sadly sign
uh unfortunately uh left
he exited stage right stage right stage
left whatever
about a year after publishing about a
year and a half
how did he kill himself let's see
how did he do it i'm not saying that
people don't kill themselves by the way
that's not my
i just think around i don't know 200
people killing themselves
that involve a family it starts to look
suspicious
i believe it begins to look a little odd
we were talking about this in the
backyard with ben
and we're saying that
you know people like uh
you know the bush family and the clinton
family uh
are how shall we say it
how do you say it they're um they like
power and they're not
huge fans of uh
people that wrong them and a lot of the
people that have wronged those families
end up in trouble
coroner releases new details about
alleged suicide of clinton tarmac
reporter christopher sein
okay what do they say in the morning is
found dead by family members
cause of death has yet to be released
but they believe it was a suicide so the
coroner's still looking through it
it might be that he
took the wrong medication i i don't know
i'm not saying that anything happened
here
uh i'm just saying it's curious
it's a curious thing
get to get him up talking about the
threats he received he's
i believe whether it was on fox or he
was talking about the threats he
received when he broke the story
i'm not suicidal by the way i know that
makes me a minority in this country at
this moment
where everybody is just on the brink um
but you know supposedly
he in a in a television interview i
watched
seemed pretty together and he was saying
that he had received some threats
and um there you go right here there you
go
you've paid the price for this
career-wise what kind of
you know what kind of threats or what
have you received well my family
received significant death threats
uh shortly after breaking this story uh
credit cards hacked
he's mentally ill my children we have
code words we have secret code words
that they know what
to do and that's why i came back to wbma
abc 3340 in birmingham
because when i was enduring the death
threats it was my former alabama
football
family and my teammates my coaches who
circled around me oh my
read all about it you can get the book
right now secret on the tarmac it's at
christopher sign
sign dot com on amazon as well all right
sure anyway
get the book where you can folks again
my family received significant death
threats you're like
oh anyway the book's out right now grab
the book if you can folks
grab the book if you can
man it's just a uh
it could be a coincidence i don't know
much about what happened
um i'm just saying
maybe he was bit by a brown recluse
is that possible that this guy was bit
by a nest of brown recluses
they're in alabama i think
is there a coroner's report on this guy
yeah but it's undetermined still
they don't know trying to find the
latest thing on it
cause of death is probably related to
suicide it's just
maybe he did struggle with mental health
i don't know i mean that seems
to not be the case
still just being invested you know if
somebody released uh broke a story that
i felt
impacted uh my chances for the
presidency
i would maybe kill them a year and a
half later when people had forgotten
about it
i'd put them on the list would you not
put them on the list
right you put them on the list
do you think the people like the hitmen
that work for them are like all the time
they're like
like again
but it's a good they're great they're
they're good like if you're a hit man do
you want them as your clients
it's that's what they call repeat
business
that's the rolodex you want because they
have problems with everybody yeah
the bushes would do a lot of shady [ __ ]
too
but they like just whacked jfk
or h dubs was clearly suspiciously well
he forgot where kennedy was
he forgot where he was when kennedy
where were you when you heard about 9
11.
uh second grade yes in class i was in uh
11th grade history class
but when they asked bush that he went ah
where were you when jfk was killed he
goes it's a japanese interview he goes
yeah i don't
i don't i don't know come to think of it
you know where he was
where dallas
[Laughter]
it's odd it's interesting he was in
tyler
yeah but it's very interesting that he
forgot like he forgotten he was like in
the state
you know he wasn't in fiji
but again none of this is important
what's
none of this is truly important what's
important is that
people continue to argue about whether
fauci
uh can you believe that he lied about
the masks
that's what's important don't get lost
in any of this stuff
the real things that matter are did
fauci
lie about needing masks early on
because that's the key to it all that
will unlock the secret
that explains everything it's not it's
not this
don't get off track here
don't get off track what matters is the
inheritance tax
when you inherit an estate how much
should you pay for it
what percentage of the estate should you
pay i'm not saying that's unimportant
but that's that's what we should be
focusing on
not whether the country is run
by murderers who
kill their enemies
in public like this is no one's even
trying
to hide anymore the killing they're used
to they used to go to great lengths
to hide the murder now they just go like
this
i mean it's you know so that's why
people when people get into politics
with me i have to like
you know just kind of like i'm i just
under the table i'm just like all right
i'm just i get bored dead thatchy lie
about the map
i i don't know that's important isn't it
killing people in front of you dummy but
it's not
laggard they passed a new law
in texas that said you could carry a gun
and do you know what that means oh you
tell me tell me what it means
you tell me what it means you've clearly
done the research
but r.i.p to christopher's sign it's
unfortunate we don't know what happened
we're not even gonna speculate we're
just having a little fun
we're just goofing we're goofing around
we don't have any information about this
our audience is not
nearly big enough for anyone to care out
there
so don't i bet this guy was sad
and that's what happened so don't come
looking for anything here we don't this
is not a journalism show
we're not breaking any news this was
talk this trended on twitter for 48
hours
i'm not breaking news nobody handed me a
usb
with any information i don't have a
flash drive
i don't know what happened to anybody
it's all a conspiracy
everything's a conspiracy like
everything's good
everything out there is good
don't worry about it it's not a big deal
it's fine there's we've got
bigger fish to fry
much bigger fish to fry than whether the
ex-president and his wife are on a
killing spree
in broad daylight or whether the other
ex-president's father
you know participated in a coup don't
get it twisted
it'd be good now if we had an ad break
for like a very mainstream
you know like i always ask why we don't
have more mainstream
but it's a great way to get out of a
meaningless political debate is to just
bring these things up
bring these things up and people will
move on very quickly
they'll change the topic by the way
they'll change it so if they start in
about the fouchy and the mask
hit him with hit him with some fun and
then they they
they move on and they ah what have you
been up to
oh that was easy just had to pull that
lever
ladies and gentlemen it is the summer
love you got to get in at blue chew
is a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in chewable tablets at a
fraction of the cost
you could take them any time day or
night you can plan ahead or be ready for
an opportunity when it arises
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best part it's all done online
so no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations
no waiting in line at the pharmacies
blue chews tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package
with bluetooth men everywhere are
excited
i have friends that use this and they
love it i need to try it myself
everyone i know loves
this if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code td at
checkout that's pay 5 shipping
that's bluetooth promo code td to
receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast
better help better atlp a lot of people
are dealing with the anxiety of going
back out and rejoining in the world well
you could start
communicating with a professional
therapist online in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professionally uh
professional counseling done securely
online it's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas
the services available for clients
worldwide betterhelphlp.comd
it's committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if needed
betterhelp.com
and if he used the promo code tim d it
would have been great he could join one
of the over one million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health he would have gotten ten percent
off
his first month at betterhelp.com
betterhelp.comd
betterhlp.com tim d i'm telling you
everybody loves this you need to do it
it'll help you it'll help assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist
so many people are using better help
they're recruiting more additional
counselors in all
50 states betterhelp.com
timd betterhelp.com timd
we went out to dinner tonight you know
again it's you just try here and you you
try to do what you can do and it just
it's you just try and um
you know the plans are in place and
there is a process and there is a
movement happening in migration west
it's our destiny
uh manifest destiny westward expansion
uh
not that i haven't enjoyed my time here
which will i'll have several more months
of it
uh and not that i haven't enjoyed it and
it hasn't taught me a lot about myself
uh and what i can and cannot tolerate i
just i would rather be stabbed in the
street
by a machete-wielding psychopath
than spend one more minute here
in in in the land of mediocrity i can't
take it i can't take
uh any more garbage food
or you know you know
c-lists like you know just just
it's a you just look at the people and
you go yeah you're just
you're almost there you're almost there
but you're not there
they're uncooked here they were taken
out of the oven too quickly
you know they're misshapen the cookies
are misshapen here
they're not cookies that you'd put in
the christmas catalog
they're cookies you can chew on them but
they're misshapen
they're not something you're proud of
you're glad they
exist sometimes you're hungry
but in reality the people here and
that's your impression
a little bit too isn't it yeah it's a
lot of uh
jeans that have been cut off with
scissors and
weird headbands you don't want to wait
her with a lebron james
headband and dreads and whatnot when
he's white when he's white he's a white
guy with dreads
yeah and then like the the the headband
like the pickup basketball headband
it's not good the horrors are unending
the brown recluse that we met has been
the least obtrusive
it's just a lot of like the waiter puts
something down and goes yeah that's real
good and i'm like
you wouldn't know what good was
if it climbed into your mouth and went
to your
brain like you would have no idea what
good was
how long ago were you in prison good
they all get so excited they're like
it's good isn't it good
and they come up to you while you're
eating it they're like isn't it good and
by the way they don't even sound like
that
i'm doing this texas accent this twang
nobody even really sounds like that
nobody has that accent that i don't even
know where that exists
but it's not here people just say it's a
little slow like
it's not that bad it's it's just a
little
yeah it's a little like high like they
weren't fully mk'd they were halfway
mkad and were released
yeah yeah i just you know
it's been lovely it's been a nice
ordeal maybe the clintons will uh
arrange it so i don't have to spend too
much time here
that's all are you worried now they say
uh the cryptocurrencies are all going
away
yeah it looks like they're plugged
they're saying the bitcoin whales are
trying to get the price to dip under 28
so they can buy it all up
that's the rumor that's the rumor right
now it's 34 000
i was paid one bitcoin for the bitcoin
convention
um and that is about what i have in
crypto right now
34 000 in crypto and then i have five
ethereum
and we're gonna hold hoddle
hold on for dear life do you have any
crypto right now in your
sizable portfolio i have none none
what are you holding on to right now
just just stonks
you're a piece of [ __ ] you have like
you're like my mother my mother had like
one share of mcdonald's
my mother would get one share of a
company she'd be like i have one share
of
exxon yeah she had like stock
certificates in a book
she had like one share of a company or
like
two or three shares of a company it's
amazing but you're not that much better
than that
no no no no our criminal friends devin
and ida own
uh a small purse
crypto little wallet right a couple
hundred bucks i think they have a couple
hundred dollars
and they watch the crypto market like
like our frenada
watches the market like her life depends
on it
and she's just on the edge of her seat
watching this
and just reading and studying she could
make so much more money on only fans
just show the cash
but she's trying to learn about uh
cryptocurrencies and central banking
central banking show your ass
she's attractive stop talking about
fiat currency show your feet and earn a
living
now i keep telling her that
i've told a lot of my friends and i
don't mean anything nasty by this in
fact i wish someone would tell me this
but we know why they're not going to
because you know i have a very
i have a specific look i told many of my
friends you should become a prostitute
you should have sex for money are you
not
listening to me well i'm thinking about
well the fiat current have sex
with strangers and have them
pay you
are you not understanding what i'm
saying
you're good-looking enough it is a
compliment yes
to tell someone that they can [ __ ] for
money
that is a compliment and if and i've had
people get offended when i've said that
people have been mad at me because i
have told them
that they should start a little a little
at a time
not like dive in but like begin to think
about
transitioning into being a [ __ ]
and they're angry at me they're actually
people have had
really bad reactions to that
piece of information which is very
logical
nothing wrong with sex work at all and i
think many people need to get off your
high horse
and and and let's get realistic
and get it and do it now before you lose
value in the marketplace you know
before you and men and women and
non-binary people we're talking to
everyone out
i'm telling most of you to become
prostitutes
that that fit a certain and even if you
don't
there'll always be some like i could be
a prostitute but it's for such
a small sliver of the population
like it's for a it's like people will
[ __ ] me but to pay to [ __ ] me
you it's gotta you have to have a real
fetish
and it's a small segment of the
population
but if i marketed myself appropriately i
could do it but so this but some of our
friends are very attractive
and there's no reason that they're
talking
all the time and they're trying to
understand the world and how it works
when they could be taking photos and
videos of themself
putting different things in their ass
is that wrong
imagine if that was your workday and you
could kind of do it
you have a look where you could do it
truly
if you wanted to become a prostitute you
would make more money on this show
like if you had an only fans what would
i do on only fans
show your dick the problem with you is
you have no
you you're you're you're very good
looking but you're
like you're you're like a dullard and
you're
you don't like your brain doesn't work
so what it is is like
the the people have to create the
fantasy completely themselves
because you you you kind of like you
look like you're a
kid that like like when you were young
like you heard a lot of loud noises and
you have that
that type of so when you you look at
someone you don't know how to be like
it's sexy
it you just you're not fully developed
in
in that way like emotionally like like
maturely
you don't i don't know if you can really
like turn it on in a but you can just do
it with photos you just get your dick
you just
jerk off on only fans do a video of me
swinging it
yeah if you have a big enough dick where
you can swing it around which we all
know you have a big dick
um if you can swing it around i don't
know if you can really swing it around
i mean you keep saying on bigger dicks
you can can you really like swing it
like that i mean
what are we talking like like uh i don't
know how much
what are the tiers like david and
goliath like the the old school
slingshot
like that i don't know what you're
saying
using biblical references we're talking
about
practical applications of what you can
do
the problem is you you when you when
people look at you
you're not there you're somewhere else
all the time
and the people want you to be kind of
there
you know what i mean yeah and i can't
really do a neck down thing
why because i don't have like a good
body like i don't have like i'm not
ripped
no it's not great but it's
fine enough it's fine for only fans
right
but you just you just have to
change the way you like interface
you know or maybe people might be into
that like like uh like
because there's a lot of like i don't
know if
that could be a fantasy like a like a
big dick autistic
like caretaker and an airbnb like
or you're like a groundskeeper with a
big dick you're just autistic
like i feel like people would want that
and that's not if i'm not trying to
offend you i'm just telling you
that's a better life than what we do
here
it's truly a better life
i see all these people out here doing
comedy starting podcasting god bless
them
but i look at some of them i go hey just
you want attention you could get in a
lot of different ways you know
that's all i'm saying we're very excited
about uh
jeff garland who is coming up
curb your enthusiasm is one of my
favorite shows and we rarely have guests
on the show
but jeff is an absolute sweetheart
he's incredibly talented the show is
great they're coming back they have a
new season i believe premiering in
september
let's figure out
see when it's coming back season 11
right
i believe so mm-hmm they've officially
renewed it
as of may 4th 2021 so it'll be coming
back soon well good
that's awesome very exciting
ray kump arriving in austin for a week
on july 1st doing a patreon a few
episodes with ray
and uh getting him some food
ready as what would you say conservative
estimate five six hundred pounds
he's not six he's uh four he's not four
to five knocking on five
probably 500 pounds he has to be put in
a car
and there's nothing wrong with that but
he's coming and we're arranging
different meals for him throughout the
day we've actually planned it
we've actually pre-ordered we've
pre-ordered food for him
so as soon as he gets here he will be
treated like a king he'll be
we'll give him the lifestyle that he's
accustomed to and we're kidding about
five but he's
big he's in the fours he's in the force
he's in the force
he's a large gentleman yeah
but he's an expert on he'll tell you
about the keto diet
i'm like i'm on kilo shut up listen to
me
because i'm doing keto now and
uh he'll ill he'll have a lot of great
ways to break down austin too
he'll have a lot of great um
uh thoughts it's very late right now
it's one is it 1 46 in the morning it's
146. i got a flight to denver boy do i
want to ditch these shows
no and the only reason is i don't know
if it's a fulca cap
i'm so mad now the comedy clubs aren't
letting people in it's just let them in
let them in who gives a [ __ ]
if you're not vaccinated already you
don't want to get vaccinated
that's fine just let everybody in
let them in and let's get back to
business baby
i'm doing like 10 shows in denver
because they're just not letting
everybody in we could have done like
five
you're literally doing today and there's
yeah i mean
there's just so much there's so much
happening very exciting stuff we're uh
we're working on all kinds of
new fun things for the show we had a
meeting today about it so get very
excited about
all of that new sketches are coming out
new things couple of really big guests
we're working on
and um we're really pumped about it
anything you have to add before we go to
uh
jeff garland uh i just want to say i
actually am a big fan of curb
i don't hit curb yeah it's a joke i know
i was making a joke
and you're you're clearing that up first
people well they don't they might not
know
but they don't care why would they care
they might start a beef online
with who with jeff be the best thing in
the world
if you box jeff garland
it would be amazing
it would be a great yeah it would be a
great thing
wouldn't it be great if like actors like
legit actors now
because of the success of like logan and
jake paul they just start
boxing they just like meryl streep
has she has no choice but to just
get in the ring and get the [ __ ] kicked
out of her
how funny would it be to see like meryl
streep getting like beaten up
because you would just be like i just
let it go
yeah like laura dern's just just yeah
laura dern
just wailing on meryl streep
like the announcers being like it's
great to see how excited everyone was
about this fight
there was so much momentum bill so much
hype built
as you see laura dern's really getting
her she's really good
and laura dern's just laying a beating
on meryl streep and everyone's so
excited and then meryl streep's all
bloody afterwards and meryl streep's
like
i never claim to be a fighter i respect
laura
i'm looking forward to doing shots with
you after this fight
and lord's like [ __ ] yeah meryl you came
in this ring
i have a lot of respect for you we made
this possible the fans made it possible
you just see laura dunn they're both
bleeding
the fans made it possible this night's
for you
and everyone's just cheering everyone's
clapping
all right jeff garland everyone
expressvpn.com
tim dillon you don't want the government
or private corporations these
[ __ ] slime balls following you around
online
selling your information to other people
you need a vpn going
even when you're incognito mode it
doesn't matter that google [ __ ]
you know what they're doing they sell
all your stuff expressvpn is an app
that equips all of your network data and
re-routes it through a network of secure
servers
that your private online activity stays
just that private expressvpn
works on all your devices super easy to
use the app literally has one button
you tap into connected your browsing
activity is secure from prying eyes
think about all the times you use wi-fi
at a coffee shop a hotel or even at your
parents house those dirt bags
well that expressvpn every site you
could visit you visit
could be logged by the admin of that
network and that's still true even when
you're in incognito mode
that doesn't mean incognito expressvpn
slash tim dillon use my link
at expressvpn.com if you enjoy this
podcast
please support us and get what you need
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-b-n
dot com slash tim dillon to learn more
protect
yourself and you get three months free
if you use our promo code
tim dillon slash tim dillon
expressvpn.com tim dylan you get three
months free
raycon earbuds are better than apple
they're offering 15 off their products
to my listeners if you go to buy recon
dot com slash tim
raycon is great i love them i have them
you look great and feel even better
they come in a range of cool colors with
customizable gel tips
included for a comfortable in-ear fit ed
raycon and raycons are built to go
wherever you go with quick and seamless
bluetooth
pairing and a compact charging case they
last for six hours they are cheaper
than apple they're just better i love
them
you get crisp powerful beats at half the
price
of other premium audio brand you know
what you know what it's like to get
chris beats in your ears
it's the best the best
listen up you can get 15 off if you
if you buy redcon.com tim
buy raycon.com tim don't do what my dad
did last year
bought five ridge wallets and didn't use
my promo code
that's fifty percent off at buy recon
dot com slash tim
it is the best thing you can do i have
them and i love them
they have like 24-hour battery life
they're so portable
where do i take them i take them
everywhere i go
on the plane on the plane on a train
in the rain raycon earbuds they're in my
ears
all the time even if you're talking to
someone you put your raycons in right in
front of them though
who cares raygun.com go to buy recon dot
com slash tim
buy recon dot com slash tim are things
good
we're coming we're we're coming back
we're we were not awesome
they're great i just i just i was at
target with my girlfriend
yeah and um i'm walking around without a
mask
probably a lot of mass people and if
they're not
uh if they haven't gotten their shots
yet i respect that
but i i i if i don't
i wore the mask religiously and i just
as
much when i don't have to out of respect
to other people even
i ain't wearing the mask yeah it's like
i mean my attitude the whole time
with the mask was it's about respect for
other people nothing more nothing less
yes that's all it is right agreed yeah
yeah and and respect for businesses
people didn't understand that like
businesses needed to open and the way
that they could open was by having these
guidelines and regulations
did they make sense i don't know but i
know that the businesses
we're not gonna know anything about all
of this right until years down the road
that's true which i look forward to
and then no one will care by the way
yeah no one will emotionally care it'll
just be interesting someone's bound to
make a great doc
or write a great book and i i don't i
think i'd watch the doc i don't know
that i'd read the book i don't want to
read the book i'd certainly watch the
doc but it'll be met with eye rolls and
who cares and who i
i've got a bunch of jokes about coveted
in my act and they're funny
and i think i got another month or two
with them and then they're done well
by the way are we on now we're going
yeah we're in we're in now
okay good so i wanted to say curb
everyone's like i bet you're doing great
stuff on covet
oh no we're not right because we're
coming out in the fall
and ain't nobody want to relive any of
that [ __ ] agreed that's number that's
that's number one and as far as my
stand-up
i'm different than a lot of comics
because
and also i'm different in this way i i
acknowledge my difference what i mean by
that
is i read the new york times
i don't think of funny things
i only get pissed or depressed i don't
make that funny
what i can do and make funny is my life
that i that i'm able to whatever is
going on in my life but
i'm smart enough after doing this i've
been a comedian for
39 years and i know that
that's not a strength of mine and nobody
wants to hear me
like i watch you on your podcast
uh uh you're you're great
at pointing out the hypocrisies of the
world
the crazy stuff and i look to you for
that i don't think anyone looks to me
for that
and i'm certainly not good at that
you're great at that well
we i got good at it i think or if i am
good at it i got
better at it during this crazy period of
time
yeah yes but it's in your nature
here's the thing tim that's [ __ ]
great how old are you now
i'm 17 no i'm 36. 30 [ __ ] six
imagine how much better you're gonna be
in 10 years
20 years wow like our
if you keep putting in the work and i'm
not talking about writing
i'm not talking about but all the work
that you need to do
as a person like everything you grow as
a stand-up
right i'm saying you only stagnate when
you don't put in the
the work of life or writing or
or going on stage you don't put in the
work you won't grow
you're gonna [ __ ] grow yeah how many
seasons do you think curb has left do
you think this is the final one
do you think you guys do a ton more you
know it's funny no one has ever asked me
that and i'm not being sarcastic
i can be skeptical i'm never sarcastic
and i want us
no no because people say uh you're gonna
do another like no one ever says how
many more can you do
i think we could maybe
do one more yeah maybe
you know larry's in his 70s he's don't
get me wrong he's in good shape genius
yeah
yeah i do both the goldbergs and curb
i'm 50 [ __ ] nine it is exhausting
it rips me apart and the equivalent
happens to larry because he's in every
scene
working every day having to be there at
6 30 in the morning
um i don't know if physically he can do
more than let's say another season right
i think he could do another
i don't know that he has two in them
when you guys were doing that
yeah when you guys were doing the pilot
you know you often hear people say when
they read a pilot
they can envision that they go we've got
a winner here we've got something big
did you guys have any idea obviously if
larry david's involved but
did you guys know that this was gonna be
what it ended up being which i think
is is is truly the greatest comedy
of the last quarter century
well you're very kind to say that and i
will take that in and say
thank you i think i'm right i mean ben
am i right there 100
yeah 100 times i was just with michael
imperioli last week hosting
yeah and i said in my opinion
the 90 minutes that was like three
seasons
of the sopranos going into curb
that 90 minutes for drama and comedy
yeah i think is the best 90 minutes in
the history of television you're
probably right
you know i i really do by the way i'm
not a
i don't have a big ego i don't think
that i or
i don't believe the hype but i have
great respect for curb your enthusiasm
and obviously great respect for the
sopranos and that
90 minutes was just
you know they use the term must watch tv
right to me
if you want to laugh and feel emotions
that's your 90 minutes all time well
both shows had
some of the the the truly great
practitioners of the art form
in it right and people like you and
larry and susie essman
one of the things that i was always
curious about uh
people have said a lot of curb is improv
how much of the show is improv
how much of it is scripted
is there a balance that's a real thing
that i'm
very curious i wanted to answer your
question earlier yes
we did we had no idea okay we were going
to become
this iconic show we what we did the key
thing that you've done in your career
what do i find interesting you have to
do what
you find interesting and if you do that
either you hit or you don't
boom that's it but that's the only way
to hit in a big way is to be yourself
so we did a show that we thought was
funny
we didn't have a clue if another human
being would like it
i did think early on that it would do
well in
england because it had a faulty towers
flavor
right um yeah um yeah
so there you go what about how much of
it is on the spot
on the fly all of it all of it
in the story larry might write in the
outline
the outlines are about seven pages long
a normal sitcom script
is about 30 some odd pages
so that's a lot of that's a big
difference and so
larry writes these scenes which we truly
improvise every once in a while there'll
be a line of like
uh jeff says this or jeff tells larry
this
which if he says jeff tells it's kind of
like i can do it any way i want well i
can do it any way i want anyhow
um so yeah now
cheryl hines susie essman you larry
richard lewis everybody on the show is a
killer
like everybody on the show is amazing
and
what is the working environment when you
have
comics that are that skilled and that
good
when you guys are improvising uh is
there just a real
understanding of of what your characters
are does anybody try to hog a scene
or steal a scene did it take a while to
because i can only imagine me and my
friends and the ideas that everybody's
trying to have the last word and
be the funniest person well with me
automatically you've got the guy that
will hang back
if other people and it's only guest
actors
who sometimes will do a little much and
we have to sort of pull back
right but in terms of the main people
it's a feeling here's the feeling and
again no one's ever asked me this
it's a feeling of trust when you know
when you walk on that set it's like
i know everyone who's here can do their
job
it's that ultimate it's walking on to an
arena with pros with people that
are equivalently on it it's like it's
like the nba playoffs are now
it's going out nobody's injured and
everybody
you know what everyone does and everyone
knows their job
sometimes you have to step up in other
ways but it's that trust factor
and what does that trust factor bring
you uh
hopefully good work but but [ __ ] joy
we la we work very hard and long hours
but we laugh all day long well that's
the other question you guys
everybody laughs it gets along is there
a and i don't know i mean this is a
question somebody probably has asked you
before it's a hack question as i ask it
but it's all right i'm so happy to be
here with you no i'm happy
that you you did it i'm this is i'm i'm
a fan of so few things
but this is something i'm a huge fan of
is there a movie
in there is there a curb movie is there
is there a long
form 90-minute two-hour
movie whether it's on hbo or it goes to
netflix like
is there a curb in my opinion yes i i i
personally don't think so and i wouldn't
aim in that direction because
i love movies and i think curb is unique
to what we do and it's a half hour
sometimes a little longer not very often
a little shorter
it isn't it's perfect for what it is to
me
i'm a believer you know movies are a
different art form
they really are 100 and it's
storytelling
but it's a different art form you go
into all right
i'm not even going to use the same genre
um
you go into most of the crime i love the
true crime stuff on netflix i watch all
of it yeah
okay and the best ones
are where the story's already been told
the night stalker
um any of those where
we know who did it and that dude
is dead right that story
however if you do five episodes it's
compelling
now so many of those
five six ten episode art uh
true crime uh documentaries are
um many episodes
too long they're they're sort of milking
it
and we get to the end and we know as
little as we did when it started
and it is it's something that could have
been
truly i'll even give them credit i won't
even say a half hour
it could have been an hour long and we
would have gotten the same
because there was one recently about the
hotel downtown
and the woman that disappears yeah no i
watched it
i said the same thing it could have been
an hour it could have been a podcast
episode yeah
so what i think we realize
about curb is it's perfect as a half
hour
maybe on occasion a special hour
if it's right but in general you don't
want to be making movies out of this
it's the same thing you know there's
nuance to
everything that's great i think and then
you know for example you know what was
great about uh sopranos
was they hired real directors it wasn't
like the writers
are gonna start directing uh uh what was
the other
thing where they all right uh um
breaking
bad better better call saul um
vince gilligan directs some of the
episodes
but mind you he's a great director right
but there's nuance
between being a showrunner slash writer
and being a director
yeah so it's the same thing whatever it
is
if you go with it you're always going to
serve
yourself and serve the people watching
who directs curb is it one person or do
you have a rotation well now
now it's been jeff shaffer i was one of
the producers direct
this year actually he directed every
episode last year we had half jeff
schaefer
have a bunch of great women directors uh
and then in the past
we've had other you know directors and
stuff uh
but um yeah it's uh you know look it's
larry david's voice
right and then tv it's just as long as
but my job
is to get when i'm doing a scene with
larry david
i'm not trying to be funny he wrecks the
scenarios they're funny
my job is to help get larry david's
story on the screen
in the best way possible well what's so
great about what you do and what your
character does what i think ben
does here is that when you put something
you add something you don't
do it all the time but it's always gold
it's always perfect
it always moves the scene to where it
needs to go it's
pivotal it's not it's never excess
that's why i was curious about
how much of it is written how much of it
is
richard lewis and bob einstein were a
little bit different they
had they would look over the scene and
richard would actually write notes to
himself and we'd do a scene
and we'd have to steal the notes away
from him because we want him to be
present
right but he would all his mind he
wanted to have
funny quips ahead of time right bob
einstein a lot of times
i would say what are you doing because
he wanted to just be
so damn funny which he was i mean one of
the
funniest people on that show
uh without question bob jb smoove
amazing and susie esman is
just i mean everything she does and says
is truly amazing when curb ends
when it ends you know down the road i
mean you're doing the goldbergs now
what is the hope how do you how does
somebody like you feel about other
things
because you've been so successful in tv
uh
how do you feel about stand-up now at
this point in your career and how do you
feel about
uh movies and other opportunities i know
you've done
some animated stuff but you know you've
been toy story you know all the pixels
well here's the thing i as long as it's
creative i'm into it
i have as a matter of fact i got a call
i didn't answer it
that's how much i'm into you i
appreciate it telling me i'm up for a
very big movie
oh good i got i got a call about it so
i'll find out when we're done
i mean like a really big move wow which
i don't get offered those
a lot but it's really exciting um
i'm developing uh three tv shows right
now like i'm always you're working
you're working yeah what are you what
what are you i actually believe in you
so much
oh anytime you want to sit and talk
about
not even with me attached as a producer
with how you could do something and what
you could do
we sit we talk we do a lot of the
talking
and i don't mind that but what we were
able to do
over the last 24 months is really build
a great show and a big following on
social media and through the podcast and
we've been able to really
we sell out every market we're doing
shows in and our you know we're number
three on the patreon which is a
subscription service
that people pay for extra content for an
extra episode
of this podcast every week and and we
focused on that because development
which i was doing for years and i had
people like adam mckay producing stuff
and anthony bourdain and his company i
mean really titans and stuff like that
but it is very difficult it's very
difficult and it's very difficult
and it's not easy and there's all kinds
of reasons why things don't work
and and and you try to understand those
reasons you can drive yourself crazy
right racking your brain you could go
i don't know why was it me was it the
idea yeah by the way it can be
everything from the development process
to one person involved in the
development not liking you or not liking
the idea
or not getting it or right um but larry
david taught me a lot and i really i am
happy to be fired i am happy to walk
away
from every project i'm involved with
right
which gives me creatively power and
financial power
because i'm like this is what i get and
also other things
i'm happy to work for nothing or next to
nothing other things
i don't do things just for the money
anymore i've gotten to a point in my
career
where i don't take money jobs the only
money jobs that i would take
and i know you would take are corporate
stand-up kids yeah i'll take them
they don't bug me but let's do it yeah
no but the truth is if you want to ruin
your event
email my agent at caa please
you say that why why are you at ca too
i'm a cia yeah
oh that's my uh that's my thing yeah i'm
with my agent is overweight everyone who
resp
represents me in the business is
overweight there's seven overweight
people in la they're all
working for me in some capacity it's
truly amazing i mean everyone
across the board from the business
managers to our business manager is not
really overweight but
but our agent is and you know everybody
uh everybody on my team
it's very interesting and blessed god
bless them they're they're working and
eating and
living um what do you think when you
look at the internet and you look at the
freedom that comics have now
wait a minute you're um hold on a second
yeah
you you're with matthew fector no i'm
with ed brooke
justin uh but do you know adam
they were they were talking to me yeah
i'm i'm i i know all of those guys
to a degree i mean they all blend into
one guy no but just know that they
talk about well that's good i call them
the josh's
where i don't know they're all names but
i know that they're whatever i'm on a
call it's josh's and
jonah's and it's a lot of jays and
people like that but i do
chism right right i do know them when
you look at the freedom comics have on
the internet now
um which seems to be the way that a lot
of people are building careers and you
you lived in l.a a long time you've seen
the growth of youtubers and social media
stars i mean people that are truly
getting hundreds of millions of views on
things
whether we like them or not or we think
they're artistically significant or not
you cannot deny the raw
power what happens to television because
it's getting less and less eyeballs i
mean you're on an iconic show
but it gets less and less eyeballs all
the time and you see this
really gravitational pull towards the
internet where people can watch things
on their phones and share things with
each other
and what happens to traditional
uh television uh in an environment where
people
want shorter form content that is more
accessible
well i think there's always room for
great
television i think there's always
there's always room for great narratives
there's here's the thing people say to
me with the with the
feeling in the country right now are you
scared about not being able to do what
you
do and no i'm not changing a thing
in my stand up right or who i am do you
know why
because i'm funny you're funny right
yeah
the people who should be scared right
now are the people who aren't that
funny right because now you look at like
some guy works for a company
he puts himself up on on facebook
doing a bad color joke or even
being in blackface well yeah that's not
freedom of speech that's called you're
about to get fired
yes you know the the freedom of speech
is nobody's going to arrest you
that's true a hundred percent 100
so so the only thing that's going to
happen in the future
is uh in terms of your your real
network shows and nothing about abcm
that's about all of them hulu
hbo everything it's just leave it to the
professionals
and i think there's always going to be
shows always going to be room
and then in terms of social media social
media
you know in instagram influencers uh uh
uh you know all the different things you
know right
um i'm here to them but i don't really
i don't pay attention to them much you
know um
are that's not a career that's a moment
right so let's say you have a you have
let's just say hypothetically the
million youtube founder uh
followers and what you do is you take
different toys
and you throw them off a roof slide them
up millions of people
you get money a lot of money from
youtube
i'm just i'm giving up a stupid
hypothetical no it's probably not a
hypothetic it's probably happening and
you're
probably excited you're right yeah yeah
yes
so those people enjoy
whatever time that is that's not how you
build a career right it's a funny
but you look at somebody like um what's
his name he's got the um
bo burnham okay paul burnham started on
youtube
got the youtube following i first heard
about him
from my managers in youtube they
actually signed with my managers are you
with three arts too
no no no no i was with someone in new
york but we got rid of them
oh jimbo [ __ ] roberts no
no no i had to think for a minute i'm
like was i with it
i interrupt
whether youtube exists or not it's going
to be a success agreed
agreed agreed and a successful director
yeah so that's my point about
all the social media influencers all but
i would
i would almost say i look at i look at
jake paul and logan paul i don't know if
that's a moment that seems to be
a moment you think that's a moment
without a doubt i mean
you know why yeah you know why they're
not intelligent
i don't know about that i mean here's
here's what he only wish i could box
both of them at the same time here's
here's why they're very in shape they're
they work very hard at it no
by the way i gotta give them credit they
work very hard here's why i'll disagree
with you on that
i think to go from making youtube videos
in your backyard
to boxing floyd mayweather you have to
have a level of intelligence
and it may not be you don't think so
no but here's what you think
here's what i think so you're a youtuber
it's starting to become a bit dead
end with what you've been doing and you
want to reinvent yourself you start
boxing
and to me his boxing and i would
i i would be shocked and i'm open to it
if he had the master plan
of where it is now when he started no
dude started boxing a thing opened up
which led to another thing right it's
called
are you ready hard work and luck hard
work agreed
dude takes his boxing agreed no i don't
think he thought
yeah but luck in terms of that it's
caught on
but let me ask you a question yeah are
you would you
really and i'm not even talking about an
age thing would you look to logan paul
for your entertainment dollar outside of
wanting somebody to fight him good
well i might not i wouldn't but i
i would say his the fight was very
entertaining and he knows how to create
spectacles
but what i will say is that there are a
ton of people who do
watch his content and enjoy
unequivocally
right and enjoy it like there's that
couple
i think they broke up where i heard
about where they had
like a kid and people were hanging out
on their block
hundreds of i mean like tons of people
and they follow them on their thing
i know a lot of people care but i think
your youtubers
in general and all of that are
the most um what's it called what fickle
like
they're here gone tomorrow that is true
unlike acting which is very solid work
but i think what you're doing i'll just
use you yeah
you're building up like people look to
you
for a point of view people look to you
to laugh
people look to you you're supplying a
lot
let me ask you yes paul brokers yes best
day ever
what are they supplying i think they
supply entertainment and spectacle
i wish
i think they will find different ways to
keep creating those types of spectacles
i think now it's in boxing
but i do think down the road it could be
it could be other things
my point is you're a comedian you're
excellent
and you're building a career you're
building
you last long enough you really build
the crew you know my
my argument has never been that the paul
brothers are going to replace
uh richard pryor no they're
the kardashians that's of this time but
don't you think and this is an
interesting conversation
do you think this time ends
does this time become another time
yes it turns into something else and
there will be a time
when the paul brothers or kim kardashian
are looking at whatever's popular
youtube who knows whatever
sure and they're going oh that used to
be me well that's that reminds me of me
that's true and that's everybody but i i
do think no it's not everybody because
look as much as i look to you and i'm
inspired by this or whatever
it's uniquely you there is nothing
uniquely them
you know maybe the kardashians more than
the paul brothers
but it's all of this time think about a
person
that watches the kardashians and is
passionately involved
those are the same people most of them
who will be passionately involved in
watching the kardashians
as 60 year olds it's like people feel
it'll feel like they haven't had growth
i feel right you have a hopeful view
and i by the way you have a view that i
would like to
see come to fruition where you know
people might move on from these things
i look at it is that you are one you're
a member
of one of the last great ensemble
comedies and i
hope that more come down the pike but
what you're saying is right there from
the standpoint of
people aren't there's no comedy movies
there's not
there's none there's no none comedy on
television
i wan i watch three i'm really involved
in three shows one's not that funny
and that's barry barry's amazing
brilliant show yeah
brilliant show but it's not i don't go
to it for laughs
for laughs i wish i had curb your
enthusiasm to go to
as someone who doesn't know what's going
on but south park is my
jam the best that's why it's the best
yes but i'm saying
that's comedy to me that lasts forever
and even them they they did a pandemic
episode
well written well done not enjoyable
didn't laugh
once really nobody watched it yeah
because it was the pandemic
i'm sick of pandemic yeah pandemic and
people like great stuff on curb i've
been coming back
no don't look to us for panda we have
two pandemic things
and one i haven't talked to larry about
this i'm going to ask him to cut
it's a scene in an elevator with larry
and i i don't really like it
in terms of time at the time i thought
oh this is
but we have another one that's the first
episode
that will get a big laugh but it's one
thing
the entire show nobody's wearing masks
no
thing because people that's not what
people want
agree not agreed how
is the your stand up
are you gonna go on the road a little
bit are you gonna go let me tell you
what i'm doing on that yeah and
i made this decision and it's a pretty
big one
starting it's up start i haven't done
stand-up yet in terms
of i've hosted a few things but i
haven't done a set
in about a year and a half and the last
time i took a break was two weeks
so it's been but i'm now sort of
developed thinking about
a new way of me doing it you know um
i hope people and if i can plug my
uh netflix special called our man in
chicago
that is me like if you want to go
do i dig jeff garland watch five minutes
of that
and you'll either be like yeah i love
this dude or like not for me
because comedy's very subjective
subjective
so i'm going out in the fall from
vancouver to rochester to nashville
to san diego all points in between i'm
doing like 14
weekends where i'm performing for free
not the audience for free for the clubs
for free because they
got hit so hard during the pandemic so
i'm paying my own airfare
my own hotel uh and i'm paying for an
opener that's great
they're gonna pay for the opening act
that's i can't obligate
i can't speak like the opening i have to
work for free and they don't make enough
money
and i'm actually getting them paid the
right amount of money
that's a great thing to do i'm doing a
tour where i make the clubs pay me more
money
to perform and it's called it's a stress
test
on their financial uh uh
you know strength so it's called it's
called 110
of the door by the way tim yeah you're
not
you're when someday and this is going to
happen
hopefully yes you're you're [ __ ]
loaded beyond belief
yeah i'm not i'm not larry david but
i've i've done well
you've done well that i can go out and
say you know what
i've had i've had the blessings i had
the blessing of
yes it was stressful of working both on
the goldbergs
and curb during the pandemic i was lucky
i got to work during the pandemic
and make what i make uh so to me
uh i um i want these clubs to
to really have a nice weekend where they
put some money
but the thing is when i was an opening
act when i was the middle act
and i went on the road i made this is
back
this is in the um late 80s early 90s i
made 600
a week as a no-name opening app for
somebody
now when you go on the road and they
have someone come in and open for you
they're making maybe fifty dollars a
show if you've done that
right and so i'm making them pay they
don't have to they don't have to book me
i'm
coming for free but my opening acts are
getting a thousand
because i feel like that's the proper
amount
that you should be paying now i'm not
talking about the first act that
well with me there's no emphasis feature
i pay my future as well too i always
give
my futures extra money i cover their
hotel their airfare all that yeah but
when they pay though
the feature x they're paying them dirt
nothing they pay
and to me uh i made 600 back then they
should be making like 1400
they don't they don't they're making
half they probably come out of a weekend
three to four hundred dollars
and i always give my future thousands of
dollars extra
you know that's always what i do uh
because i want them to live and we're
doing really well now we're sorry
and by the way that's another thing when
i'm on the road
these are young comics that but not all
very young
these are comics that didn't make good
money during the pandemic
so i want them to get some money too i
want to it's go actually the name of the
tour is the use me tour
use me i'm good bill withers yes use me
i love it few more questions what do you
whatever you want to ask me
and by the way you can go anywhere with
me yes so
the middle east no i'm kidding but no no
i appreciate that
but it is fascinating i don't talk to
too many people that have been on such
an amazing show so it does interest me
like
that's genuinely interesting what do you
feel uh the future is
of specifically
comedy because you said there's not a
lot of comedy movies
and you said there's not a ton of comedy
on tv comedy seems
people want a lot of people out there
want
you know a genre blending or they want
it to have a little more gravity
than it used to they wanted to be a
dramedy i hate that
[ __ ] word but whatever but what do
you think the futures and
you know not to overstate it because
there's a little bit probably too much
made of this but like people are
people are more sensitive now it is a
different world now things are changing
what is the future of comedy
uh content whether it's television okay
yeah
so you brought up something very
interesting there
when i was a young comedian it was all
about
having the respect of your peers and
being great
right the audience and by the way this
is not an insult to the audience
it was about developing being great and
having your peers go what you're doing
is great and you get the audiences left
i remember when i was a young comedian
i would get laughs on things that are
embarrassing you know
you know my whole life was about
cartoons tv
sex it was like it was it was like there
was no substance to it
but i killed so it's not about the
killing but here's the
here's the way comedy has become like
every
other mainstream art form
no one ever gave a crap if audiences
like you or you became famous
right now we're living in a time where
when you go to the comedy store
and let's say there's 12 comics on a
couple different shows
and we've had at least a third of those
comics are only there because they're
popular
not because they're funny uh bill
parcells
i saw an interview with him a while back
he was talking about a football player
and he said this guy plays because he
loves
football football is everything tim he
loves football
not what football can bring to him and
unfortunately we've crossed over in
comedy
where most of it is about
becoming famous and what comedy can
bring to you
i know myself i can speak for myself and
larry david because we've had
conversations
jb smooth too we do comedy because it's
what we do
i have no choice what else can i do i
might be a good teacher
i might be uh a good therapist maybe
i don't know but i was i've been wanting
to do this since i'm a little boy
eight years old i knew i wanted to be a
comedian so it's
what i do i love comedy i
don't do comedy to get a good table in a
restaurant
i don't do comedy although i don't
begrudge any
anyone uh for early in their career to
get laid
like you know i do comedy because it's
what i do and the fact that the audience
digs me
i am i'm so lucky and and i combined
two things which is i'm supremely
confident in my skills
but i'm also humble for any opportunity
i love being on your show
i don't think like oh this is a get for
tim dillon i think
how great i'm gonna be with tim yeah how
much fun
i called you and said well i was i was
so
i was really honored that you liked the
show that you were a fan of the show i
was honored because again you're part of
what i consider you the best comedy of
the last uh a quarter century
you know pamela's says son of course
yeah pamela
is the one who turned me on you okay she
was the one who said
this guy she didn't say anything but
like hey he's great
wow and then i did a deep dive and i'm
like you are
so [ __ ] right i appreciate when you
when you started out did you start out
in new york or did you start out west
coast
south florida the comic strip i started
with brian regan
in the early 80s did he go did he go on
to any success
i'm kidding
yeah so that's where i started from
there i went to new york chicago
back to new york to l.a chicago i did
second city
like i did a bunch of stuff but it was
only my journey i loved it
you know i i yeah what do you think
mistakes are the people are
when people start now
a couple things i once want to finish up
the thought about what comedy
has yes i frankly think there are a
million comedy movies
that are going to be coming right like
it's all it's just of a time it's just
like
we got lazy with this we didn't do this
we didn't develop this
it's just of this time it'll all grow
i'm sorry comedy great comedy has been
around
since at least on screen since the teens
of the last century you know silent
movies uh
um there's always where people always
want to laugh
but you also have to make a a good
comedy
you also have to have to have a studio
exec or a network exec who goes
you know what you're doing i'm going to
give you suggestions
but you know what you're doing as
opposed to you're
i've been in movies before and tv shows
where creative decisions are made by
people
who shouldn't be allowed 100 miles from
a creative decision
right not that they can't say what they
want and i work with people and i'll
call them [ __ ]
who gave in right away right oh that's
what you want us to do
i bet i was on a show where they
listened to every network note
and we were cancelled after six episodes
right
and it's like what happened yeah you
have to fight and you have to fight them
and pick your battles
yeah yes what mistake do you think it's
all gonna happen
what mistake do you think young people
make when they start today
because they're concerned with social
media and then i say
use it for what it's worth like for
example you have taken what you do
and you've used social media to your
strengths yeah
i think if you want to make short films
put clips up on instagram
or what's the other one that uh twitter
any of them twitter
that one not twitter yeah yeah what i'm
saying
so get a youtube or what's the other
video site i forget
um i don't know vimeo
you know i'm saying get a channel on
there put up your
full length 10 minute shorts but put
clips the way
the way a lot of stand-ups do i don't
i've done it once
and i got the links from that's why i'm
amazed that the guy is successful is
let's say
jim gaffigan who i respect the [ __ ] out
of master who i
i love him as a man i love him as a
comedian all that
but i look on his instagram and the
fucker's
constantly promoting himself in a great
way right like in a way of like
how do you have time right or who who
did you hire can i hire them
right so i think that the mistake that
people
are they that i see young people make
is they're very concerned with what
comedy brings to them uh
me i fall in love and i'm talking male
female i don't care
i fall completely in love with any
comedian that only gives a [ __ ] about
being funny
and becoming better tomorrow than they
were today
anyone who's focused on fame i really
and i could say names and you'd go
really and i go yep that [ __ ]
it's about fame that ain't about i gotta
do this i gotta release what's inside of
me
like i could see you yeah if you
i think if comedically you didn't
release
who you are it'd be the equivalent of
you not being out
yeah it would be a problem yeah they're
both
they're not doing either i think they're
equal problems yes
because you uh when i watch this
when i when you do stamp anything when
you're done i have a piece of you with
me
yes that's that's what i don't see
yes people just want to go up there they
say their funny thing they're like
please like me and then they i've got
more followers or
i did this and people no just
whatever it is that you bring do it up
the problem
the problem is that so many people right
now bring so little
and it's not oh oh my god
oh my god yes it's like you know
nothing makes me happier okay i'll give
you i'll give you a happy
when i sit in the original room and i'm
in those back chairs
and i'm watching rick ingram yeah i am
so
happy dude's funny funny [ __ ]
yeah
he can't get arrested because he's just
a regular white dude
right he just doesn't you know but [ __ ]
he's great
i watch him so i love settling in that
seat and i want to say to whoever's on
stage
take me on a journey take me on your
journey that only
you can bring me on with your point of
view and yes it's filled with [ __ ] but
you know what
since i started they're always you've
always had to swim through the ship
swimming through the [ __ ] is the
most unbearable aspect of doing what we
do
because there's so much of it and so
many people who only give a [ __ ] about
being famous
you know and that's not the thing the
thing is about being great
if you're great and you put in your work
you will
get whatever kind of following you
deserve or not even deserve you'll get
some following of
substance you know yeah well the
happiest people that i know
in this business truly are people who do
it on their own terms whatever that
means
by the way that's what i here i am i'm
saying i've been doing this for 39 years
i aspire to do that every day
right what can i bring what can i do
yeah that's all it is and the people
that like when when somebody like you or
susie aspen walks on
to the senate curb they're bringing
something when i go and i watch
people at the comedy store uh go up and
do their set
whether it's uh whoever it happens to be
they're bringing something
um you know i think that that that's the
hardest thing to do is to not make it
so hard well you've heard a million
times it takes 10 years
yeah like to become a good comic the
point being is
it takes a lot of people 10 years just
to be comfortable with who they are on
stage
it takes a lot of people sometimes 10
years to be comfortable who they who
they are
off stage by the way i would i would
argue
longer longer because i've been i'm in a
lifetime journey
sometimes i look at a comic or i look at
a person and i go
you don't know who you are you've never
met yourself and i think those are the
people who are doing themselves a
disservice because by the way god forbid
you do get famous as uh a character or a
version of yourself who you're not
you have to play this role your entire
life i know a few people that have done
that you get trapped and it becomes a
hara
so well by the way know who you are and
figure that out before you get
big i'll show you that i'm not as scared
to talk about things crystalia
crystallia
is there a handbook for being extremely
handsome
extremely charismatic becoming famous
and women of all ages and i'm not
talking about minors although i'm sure
there's some
people under 18 who dig him um
throw themselves at you where's the
handbook to figure that [ __ ] out and not
have a big ego
and not believe the heights right you
know now he's humble
now he gets right you know i i would see
him at the club i think they had the
only handbook i think is probably the
law
i mean that's probably the thing oh yeah
well we're talking to underage
yeah that's the only half month whatever
but i get it i understand what you mean
i understand what you mean there's going
through this thing
is very confusing it's very hard it's
very very very tough confusing
the best thing one of the best things i
ever wrote that's not funny
for me was on my instagram when it
describes i said
comedian of some notoriety completely
true i can't gauge it
uh doing the best i can with the
information
that i've been given that's great
because that's all you can do
that is all you can do you learn and by
the way i've seen people
who early on in their success believe
the hype and they were kind of [ __ ]
and they turned into substantial people
it's called growth it's called living
life
you know um but it's it's it's a very
hard adventure to go through the whole
thing it is jeff garland i
i truly appreciate your time i i'm a
huge fan of the show
it's one of the shows i look forward to
watching uh i think it's
probably again it's definitely gonna go
down in history
as one of the greatest comedic shows
that has ever you know been done
and uh i really like that you enjoy some
of this
stuff we do on the show i i really
appreciate that you recognize the humor
of it
can i really be honest with you yeah
i've you've never pissed me off which
isn't quite the economy
for example i auditioned wait what role
did i report oh yeah
michael does make everyone no but i
love michael as a man yeah i love him
comedically
i love him as an actor and i love most
of his posts
so he put up a post on instagram
recently of
this kid who looks just like my younger
son
on the street doing like rap with his
friends they set the street
some guy gets out of his car and punches
him in the head
and then when you slide over to the
second thing it talks about how that guy
got arrested
he's in jail but i can't on
and remember whatever i can't get out of
my head the image
of this kid who looks like my younger
son getting punched
yes yeah and i'm like dude why are you
shocking me i don't need you i need well
he might be a little lost and this is
with trump not being in office because
he was so good
at nailing trump all the time yeah
that's what a lot of people's life was
about yeah
well by the way it's killing talk shows
right now
because you know steve colbert comes out
and talks about trump it's like we don't
care
right no one can don't want to hear
about it it's true certainly
the people that love trump don't want to
hear what steve colbert is talking about
right so it's an audience of no one
i auditioned what did i audition for on
curb a realtor plumber
i just for the role of a plumber on curb
i didn't get it
job i think i did a good job with the
audition no but you did yeah that's not
the point the point is
that uh you could have easily gotten
that or not got it it's all
larry's whim of course on that [ __ ] of
course but you were great
and you'll get other things and
hopefully if we do another season of
curb that i have you on it yeah
i want to but i want to do other things
with you of course
i want to see you become so supremely
successful wow that's
what i love and by the way i've
witnessed since she first pointed you
out to me
you're going from an unknown comic
to holy [ __ ] this fucker's kicking ass
well thank you son we try and we we
try to be as funny as we can and ben
does a great job and we try to do it
as much as we can and we're working on a
book and we're working on
yes we're doing a lot of different
things and we hope they're good
but you do this because it's what you do
if me and ben weren't doing this we'd be
in a diner
doing this and that's the difference
right right so that's
that's where we are jeff garland you're
the best we really appreciate you coming
on
and good luck a joy a joy thank you
and we will talk to you so when are you
coming back home i'm yeah
well the fall i'm on tour all summer and
then we're going to start looking at
places in the fall
and we're we'll be back home we we tried
austin texas
i've been uh i've been quite vocal about
my thoughts and feelings on austin
people
by the way that all made me laugh i've
performed in austin
performed in austin yeah and had a nice
time but that was probably the last time
i performed an awesome might have been
five years ago
yeah it is not the scene it's turning
into something else
one every f once every five years i
think is good
jeff garland thank you do we'll do so
much
we'll do a dinner when i get when i'm
i'll be there over the summer we'll
we'll do a dinner
i'll be here too all right brother good
luck thanks so much thanks for
everything
bye